one again
again
ah happy friday everyone it's almost the
weekend i can tell because cat's liver
hung up it's do not disturb sign
[Laughter]
i swear i would stop but i lied i can't
i can't
so is it time to declare this national
experiment over the one where we handed
america over to a guy who gets lost on
the way from the toilet to the sink
there's not a single optimistic photo of
joe biden that we can find
it's all like he's got a migraine
and so do we let's assess the mess right
now we see plunging enrollment in public
schools even the ones where hot teachers
bang the male students
people are leaving the hellish prisons
faster than felons leaving actual
prisons in california
gas is climbing to 10 bucks a gallon
they're talking about rationing if biden
were any farther back into the 1970s
he'd be peeing down the leg of his
bell-bottoms
the only formula for babies that the
dems can find is abortion
yeah huh pretty yeah thank you
which is a shame because now
even men can get pregnant
what do you say a woman is
i believe that everyone can identify for
themselves
okay
um
do you believe then that men can become
pregnant and have abortions
yes
[Laughter]
she's nuts
look he's got crazy crazy eyes
well that's going to ruin the nfl
sorry tom brady's day to day with
morning sickness
so as our education system implodes
teachers are sent to sex fetish
conferences
i could just see a math teacher teaching
kids how to count to 20 while he sucks
on his life partner's toes to do so
it's real
this as kids experience the highest
rates of mental illness on record only
to be taught by their teachers
funny how being masked and locked down
will do that to a young person just ask
the jehovah witness tied up in my
basement
meanwhile panic dams demand
investigations into domestic terror as
their disinformation board implodes
faster than a chris wallace talk show
as this goes on netflix scraps all its
woke programming the world's richest man
once a die-hard democrat now says he's
voting republican
hell at this point george soros must be
having second thoughts
interestingly the public seems immune to
the democrats jitting up anti-republican
rage
and poor antifa
fuel prices are so high instead of
molotov cocktails writers have to throw
shirley temples
so what's going on here are we realizing
this ain't right anymore are we waking
up and is this the true definition of
being woke makes sense we let the
lunatics take over the asylum and now
the streets look like mental hospitals
minus the indoor plumbing
smash and grabs continue unabated
drugstores shut down as the street drug
trade ramps up that includes fentanyl
and the pepsi they stole from walgreens
i'm surprised they're not honoring
coupons gang crime turns sections of
major cities into no-go territories and
the street poopers they go anywhere they
want to go
disaster
and our government
well they believe the answer is
investigating you with the fbi meaning
full-blown idiots are you a school board
terrorist or a pronoun abuser did you
dare ask why that blue haired teacher
had the communist manifesto in one hand
and a sex toy in the other and what do
either of those have to do with third
grade math
and they claim we all follow the
replacement theory but only the left
seems to know what that is
and why well they wanted the votes but
they also want cheap labor just like
they did back in the 1850s a lot of
other states are heading toward
increasing diversification toward
demographic changes that mean
a less red state future for them i
really think because of demographic
changes in this country i think that the
democratic party is going to win texas
moving forward and the democratic party
is going to be in power for the next 30
40 years texas have had on this sort of
long-term project of of trying to take
some red states across the sun belt and
flip them blue as demographic changes
are taking place there and the
demographic change that's happening in
america right now gives the upper hand
to democrats
so
assuming one group thinks a certain way
what a bunch of racists
anyway i list all this stuff because
something's happening i call it the
great awakening the public's waking up
because unlike the media you exist in
the real world you make a living in the
real world and face challenges every day
in the real world so when the public
looks at a problem it's with a mental
dashboard and we see the red engine
light flashing it tells us that more
criminals and fewer cops equal a crime
wave that math so simple only a
socialist could
we see the wokism the indoctrination the
moves against
the moves against free speech we can see
it because we have the tools to see it
the dems can't see it because they have
only one filter and of course that's
race so when crime goes up they blame
racism kids get lousy educations they
blame racism when a billionaire buys
twitter hell he must be racist when
their bread goes stale racism when they
get a flat racism how did this happen
well when you decide that patriotism is
oppression you got to replace it with
something and that's identity politics
that's their replacement theory but it's
like trying to replace sugar with sweet
and low the people who love sugar can
tell how horrible it is right away but
if your country can't be forgiven based
on the original sin of slavery then you
can't be patriotic you can't love this
country all you can do is destroy it
and it's much easier to burn buildings
than it is to make them we see this
clearly now in america we understand our
faults our blessings our need for
cooperation unity and love we understand
that identity politics offers none of
that if you don't believe that look at
our competitors ratings
that's called empirical evidence
thankfully we're in this together and
we're gonna pull this country out of
this malaise like a fireman or cop pulls
a drowning dog out of a frozen lake and
we'll do it whether the idiot in charge
likes it or not with his popularity so
low and gas prices so high i wonder what
he
thinks all right all right look
so gas places are up my popularity's
down
i don't care
i don't even care anymore who cares who
likes me it doesn't matter uh
my wife likes me she's a doctor
and besides i got a friend
lady gaga
she told me
when she was in high school nobody liked
her
and uh you know they made fun of her and
now she's lady gaga
so i'll be like her
i have my moment
i'm on the edge of glory
let's welcome tonight's guests
like a lego figurine you'll immediately
forget his face in just a few minutes
fox's contributor tom chalu
she's so bright you'll see spots when
she leaves fosus contributor at
townhall.com editor katie pavlich
he's the biggest name from mckenzie
pennsylvania because he's the only name
from a country pennsylvania tv rider and
producer adam yenzer
and
like your carry-on luggage she's got a
tough exterior but fits in most overhead
storage bins
boxes contributor cat tip
tom how you doing doing great greg i
love the new studio yeah it's fantastic
you know one thing hasn't changed greg
we get water you get water and a
lifesaver yes i do i do i guess i guess
this is what success tastes like
one day you will taste it as well
but only if you stick by me that's right
if you ever stray you're dead to me and
i will ruin your career
just like i did to that conan guy
[Laughter]
or the guy that was his partner remember
that tall weirdo he's a good guy oh is
he yeah oh you're friends
i don't know you know what shut up
so everything tom everything the media
thought would happen under trump is
actually happening under biden yeah and
it's all happening oddly at once it
feels like a great unraveling and that's
the funny thing is that it's all going
wrong and this is when they decide to
have the kink conference
and invite teachers it's so weird i
don't even know any of that stuff that
they're doing but that the whole thing
is the thing that's so bad about it is
they're they've made it
normal like now that they have uh
teachers
and they're teaching this stuff in
school it's taken the whole mystery
years ago like if you were a ceo or a
high-end bond trader you know you'd hire
a woman to put on heels and step on your
back or whatever they do right whatever
they do yeah
i wouldn't know but now what are they
gonna do say yeah
go ahead now what are they gonna do it's
like if they once they make it normal
then the ceo is gonna have to do
something even crazier no i disagree the
kinkier it gets the more mundane your
extremes will become like you will
actually pay women to cook you a pot
roast
yeah that conference was for the people
who were presenting at the conference
because i read about it and it was like
they talked about their fetishes and
some of them involved this and it's like
that's only for the people who want to
talk about that stuff that's not
educational for anybody yeah well yeah
what we're talking about there was this
philadelphia a sex conference for
teachers who teach kids and like all the
stuff was all this kinky crap
and it was like i was thinking about
that it's like this is what happens when
you got rid of the sex phone lines
right
because that's where you would go and
talk about this crap i don't use the
phone no it's a phone line yeah what's
the phone
always had lots of charges from the 900
number yes and you knew that something
of course it was a psychic hotline let's
broaden this discussion beyond
perversion katie i don't know how we got
there but with tom here you never know
um
do you feel as i do
if you feel as i do that like the
country is kind of waking up or there's
something going on you know it's like i
think netflix is because netflix is a
liberal company the fact that they're
canning all this woke crap is amazing
yeah and also
yes very good thing
you didn't even have to say anything i
know you're just so good at expanding to
a classier conversation yes everybody
just loves it uh
when you look at the polling numbers for
joe biden especially in the direction of
the country when 21 of people say the
direction the country is great i'm like
who are these people yes like who where
are they living what are they doing
they need to maybe be in charge because
everything else is not working out for
people um but you know i think people
are realizing that when you take a
position as a company you're alienating
a number of people for business purposes
they don't take the michael jordan
stance of republicans by
nike or shoes too right and i think
people are just sick of being lectured
about morals from people who don't hold
themselves to the same standards whether
it's covid or
climate change for example you know john
kerry is telling us we all need to drive
electric cars and not travel well he has
a private jet and gets to wherever he
wants for the sake of climate change so
i think everybody's just tired of being
lectured to by people who think they are
moral bettors and they're sick of it i
think too it's a
also i think a lot of this wokism stuff
is a luxury in good times right and now
they brought us into bad times and that
gotta go
weird thing adam that i've noticed yeah
uh the mainstream media now covering
hunter biden
it seems to me that now they're even
deciding that they
joe's the wrong horse and they got to
get him out yeah you know i don't know
and turn on 100 way to do that i think
hunter might be the one percent that
still supports joe biden
when they do those polls it's hunter
biden and the anchors at cnn and that's
the entire percentage that are still
still supporting joe biden they all live
in the same place yeah but hell yeah or
heaven
depending on what you're into right tom
did you learn that at the conference
no
i was gonna say uh they've turned now
the hunter biden story i guess is okay
to report on now yeah exactly it's not
for no and i think i think what's
happening is they're trying they are
panicking because the democrats see
there's no way out and i i i mean
they had a number of opportunities
i think they're going to count on the
roe v wade thing helping them out but
it isn't moving the dial at all they're
hoping you know any kind of thing the
racism card anything it was clear that
they that roe v wade leak was to gin
people up for the election because they
have nothing else going for them right
now yeah they have nothing else to get
their base going even his own party's
turning against him now yeah it's kind
of exciting cat isn't it
aren't you thrilled
it takes a lot to it takes a lot to
thrill me
[Laughter]
tom knows this lady oh yeah yeah yes
i think that the problem with biden it's
a double-barreled shotgun of problems
because he's an empty vessel and then it
and then what filled the void was
woke-ism so if he was just incompetent
there might have been some moderates to
take his place but instead
he's an empty vessel and it was replaced
by something even worse which are these
like
infantile minds who want to destroy you
know anything that's successful yeah
it's just so strange what they choose to
focus on right like okay less than one
percent of the population is trans and
even smaller percentage of that is trans
men an even smaller percentage of that
is trans men people born as women who
transition to men who will get pregnant
right and then even smaller of a
percentage than that is
those people who would give
how you talk about pregnancy right it's
such a small which means it has to be
about something else which i think it's
self-serving because it's an easier way
for them to say look how caring and
compassionate we are and how much you
know better educated and and smarter i
am than you are because it can't really
it mathematically doesn't make sense
that it's about what they say it is yeah
if you cannot actually i think that they
uh uh they deliberately do not do a head
count on this because they wouldn't
break triple figures it's probably like
ten yeah or twelve really of a of quote
pregnant men thank god they're okay yeah
well which again you know all right if
someone told me yeah i identify as man
and i pregnant i'd say the same thing i
would say anytime someone tells me
they're pregnant which is just okay yeah
yeah
yeah
just don't invite me to the baby shower
yeah please
and we're good congrats what i found you
can't do those just walk up to a man and
congratulate him on being pregnant yeah
most of the time yeah i am very very
offended i do have to say i'm very
[Applause]
i'm very disappointed in all of the
chest-feeding pregnant men for not
making up for the baby formula shortage
exactly you know chest feeding all of
the babies i know it's awful all right
up next would you stab your colleague in
the back over the face mask that they
laughed hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else